now just like with circles you have to
do examples which require completing the
square we all had a convenience where in
whatever you know in your 10 whenever
you learn because you like I can just do
the formula British back to write you so
much simpler okay but completing the
square remains useful actually for
questions like this so let's have a go
at let's do this one
so here is the equation of an ellipse ad
job is to find all of these guys or in
fact all of the features set up program
director says okay so being that these
are we want to find you can read them
off if you can get it into this form yes
so how do we twist and turn this what
are you gonna do okay so the first thing
I want to do is do a bit of sort of
combining stuff yeah so for instance if
4x squared - 24 X then 4x squared 24
heads their exes together good you've
got your 9y squared and your - 36 y
their Y's together what should we do
with this constant I should kick it over
this side okay even though it's minus 36
it should get fixed up when we complete
the square and beside we want all of the
concerts on this side anyway all right
what am I going to do this I can't
complete the square just yet what I need
to do completing the square at least the
back of we've learned only works on
monic quadratics okay where the leading
coefficient this guy and this guy where
they are just what that's armonica means
yeah so I'm gonna need to do some
factorizing here first I'm gonna have to
do it twice once for the x's and once
for the wines so far so good
okay now I can complete the square
I'm gonna add two numbers what do I add
here what do you complete the square
you take that coefficient there right
you do two things to it ya have it and
you square it have it then square it so
Harvey and gives you three squared is
your time okay now don't forget since I
have a for at the front there okay
you're actually not adding 9 to both
sides you're actually adding page six
beginners error
okay people see the plus sign and they
add nine over here and they wonder why
terror lips is senators okay so in fact
I'm gonna add numbers as I complete the
square gonna do to both sides at once so
I might study six I'm gonna add 36 okay
let's just do it the other one
what's 9y squared minus 4y one way up
which means again I added 36 so okay now
what
I can do two things really at once kind
of if you feel uncomfortable you can do
this in two steps I'm going to factorize
and at the same time I'm going to divide
okay if you want to break that up onto
two lines that's fine okay what do you
get here that's X plus 3 divided by 9
this will be Y minus 2 divided by C what
I've done that 36 is going to become the
one that we were after okay excellent
so there was the first kind of major
hurdle we got over we've got the into
this form so now how do I get from that
fall to all of this rubbish well I can
do HK that's nice and easy because H and
K are in the equation that I form so the
center I can already read not it is
minus three comments I think great but
to get the photon the director sees I'm
missing a piece
what piece are missing I'm missing the
eccentricity okay so which important
thing did we use to find the
eccentricity of something like this
what's the assumed okay B squared equals
a squared 1 minus good ok we have a
squared now B squared they right there
okay so let's stick a min show
so we'll check out look happy so now I
take the square root
okay so we're more or less there
do we need to finish it off what do you
guys reckon you can do the monkey work
okay see you keep up with me if I can do
it faster than you on a whiteboard
that's a bit embarrassing H equals three
is equal to three as well okay so
therefore when FERC I should be at 3
plus or minus 3 times root 5 on 3 comma
okay whoops okay so that's equal to
let's see cancel cancel plus or minus 3
minus plus moved under
Desi's I'm home yeah what out the quick
alright yeah what I'm sorry that should
be there that's what it okay director
sees they actually kind of simpler to be
honest cue to have to worry about the
wine comments and age equals minus three
plus or minus so that's minus 3 plus or
minus that three guys on the top you
mean like that rather than say two
places okay you might be safe yeah so if
I were you at the end okay what you want
to write is plus or minus means x equals
I generally write the negative one first
because to the left
so minus nine on route 5 or x equals
minus three plus five and I guess the
sand goes yeah
tell you it all that's the same let me
finish yourself you've got minus 3 minus
root 5